foreign
[Music]
is in the middle of what could be its
third Civil War since Independence in a
country traditionally dominated by the
military fighting Brooke out in
mid-april to take control of Khartoum
the Sudanese Capital the troops loyal to
the general who presided over the
country were facing the militia led by
the man who up until then had been his
vice president four months later the
struggle continues Khartoum is being
devastated and the violence has spread
to other parts of Sudan taking on the
overtones of an ethnic conflict that
looks very bad the country is descending
into chaos at the moment there are no
reliable figures but everything
indicates that the number of fatalities
in these four months amounts to around 5
000 and the fighting has caused the
displacement of more than 2 million
people and many people think I'm not
that bothered about Sudan I don't even
know where that is well Sudan matters
much more than you think
similar in size to Mexico Sudan is the
third largest country in Africa and was
the largest of all before South Sudan's
Independence it occupies a strategic
location since its Coastline has access
to the Red Sea through which routes that
account for about 10 of all World
Maritime trade pass in addition it has
significant natural resources it has oil
I mean it's not exactly swimming in
dinosaur juice but it does have modest
crude oil production but above all it
has gold so much gold as to attract the
attention of Russia or at least of the
Wagner Group which has links to one of
the factions fighting in Sudan while
cashing in on its called Holdings as if
all of this were not enough in Sudan we
also have a clash between two
traditionally Allied countries we are
talking about Saudi Arabia and the
United Arab Emirates which are
supporting different sides
what's more you should care about Sudan
because it could turn into an absolutely
Savage War you know that conflicts in
Africa tend to escalate into a bloodbath
U.N Secretary General Antonio guterres
has already sounded the alarm Bells the
entire neighborhoods have no running
water and limited electricity supplies
and more than two-thirds of hospitals
near areas of conflict cannot function I
am particularly concerned by reports of
gender-based and sexual violence and by
the ethnic dimension of the violence in
Janina targeted attacks against
civilians based on their ethnic
identities could amount to crimes
against humanity so you see even if it
is purely out of humanitarian interest
you have to know what is going on in
Sudan so the question is why is such a
brutal conflict broken out in Sudan what
are the interests of the powers behind
both sides what could happen in the
coming months today on visual politics
we're going to ask her all of these
questions but first let's look at some
history
[Music]
horseback
in the early 19th century the rulers of
Ottoman Egypt conquered what today
corresponds to most of the territory of
Sudan it was not until 1899 that Sudan
became a Dominion of the British Empire
this Colony gained its independence in
1956 and lots of you will say well
that's great news how nice the Sudanese
could decide their future by becoming a
democracy well unfortunately that wasn't
to be the case
Sudan is the African country that has
suffered the most coup d'etats since its
independence 16 coups have taken place
six of which have been successful in
this way the military have put an end to
three attempts to establish democracy in
the country the most recent of which was
in 2021. Sudan has also experienced two
Civil Wars one of 17 years and the other
of 22 years the conflict that broke out
in April threatens to be the third
Sudanese Civil War
you heard correctly out of the 67 years
of the Republic of Sudan they have been
fighting for 39 years more than half of
them it was South Sudan's struggle to
create an independent state with a
majority Christian population while the
rest of Sudan was essentially Muslim
finally the South Sudanese won their
independence in 2011. they took 25 of
the territory and 75 of its oil reserves
that's right with an agreement to share
this wealth however these resources have
been of little use to the world's
youngest country because surprise
surprise in their 12 years of
Independence they have already had their
own seven-year Civil War but wait a
minute because the two Civil Wars are
only part of the Sudanese tragedy then
there is also the darfurer conflict that
is what the UN Secretary General Kofi
Annan called it in 2006. Anand calls
Darfur world's worst humanitarian crisis
in 1989 General Omar al-Bashir came to
power in Sudan he ruled the country for
30 years and established a dictatorship
dominated from Khartoum by an islamist
elite however things were different in
the peripheral regions of the country in
the Darfur region black African ethnic
groups dedicated mainly to agriculture
such as the fur the zagawa and the
massillet coexisted with a population of
Arab Origins dedicated to pastoralism
cattle breeders and Farmers regularly
fought over territory in 2003 the
African ethnic groups fed up with a
neglect by which they were subjected by
the central power in Khartoum broke out
in Rebellion Bashir sent in the Army
then he turned to the janjaweed
[Music]
[Applause]
janjaweed means demons and horseback and
is the name of the militia used by the
government of Sudan as a
counter-insurgency force against ethnic
Africans faced with little progress by
the Armed Forces Bashir armed Arab
nomadic cattle herders and Unleashed
them on black African Farmers ethnic
cleansing was brutal with 300 000 killed
and up to 2.7 million people driven from
their homes
Sudan's military dictatorship already
had a track record that speaks for
itself it had been one of four countries
in the world that supported Saddam
Hussein when Iraq invaded Kuwait and it
also hosted Osama Bin Laden who ran
Al-Qaeda training camps in Sudan and for
a few years prior to 9 11. so when the
government of Sudan commissioned the
janjaweed to do the Dirty Work in Darfur
Bashir became the target of all
criticism culminating in this situation
in 2010. international criminal court
issues arrest warrant for genocide
against Bashir Bashir became the first
sitting head of state with a warrant for
his arrest by the international criminal
court it didn't do much good because
Bashir continued to rule Sudan as if
nothing happened but now I ask you if
you were the top ruler of Sudan what do
you think would be the only way to lose
power besides dropping dead exactly a
coup d'etat
to protect himself from his own Armed
Forces Bashir officially regulized the
janjaweed by turning them into the rapid
support forces his own praetorian guard
he placed his right hand man in Darfur
Muhammad hamdan tagalo a warlord who
calls himself hemedati at the helm but
Bashir failed to see his ambition no one
likes to eat Crumbs from a feast
Everyone likes to sit at the table
internationally isolated the Sudanese
economy was deteriorating and shortages
were increasing popular protests
followed one after the other and in
April 2019 they achieved their goal even
so to overthrow Bashir it would take yes
you guessed it akudeta the Armed Forces
gave Bashir the final push when he saw
that his dictatorship was at death's
door and hemedati supported the coup
Bashir was Expendable but losing their
privileged possession in Sudan was
something neither the Armed Forces nor
hemedati were willing to allow and as we
see on visual politic no sooner said
than done Sudan's top General sworn in
as leader of new ruling body General
burhan became the head of state of Sudan
by presiding over the new Sovereign
council at his side he placed hamedetti
as vice president because of course you
can't let loose the guy who leads the
janjaweed an armed force of 100 000
soldiers now all of this was not exactly
a reason to celebrate for the Sudanese
the people had not risen up against
Bashir to keep things the same so the
military made a pact with the civilian
leadership they would share power until
elections were held in 2022 with these
ingredients and Sudan's track record
what could go wrong in the transition to
democracy yes you guessed it basically
everything check this out
the dist State versus the African
pre-gosian
the 2019 power sharing agreement between
civilians and the military was very
fragile why well because basically there
are countries that may be much wealthier
but there are very few in which you can
get richer from power at the same level
as in Sudan former dictator Bashir had
130 million dollars in cash found in his
home yep you heard that right in cash he
controlled the Sudanese economy through
the military and of course the other
generals do not have empty Pockets
either so when the new civilian
government aspired to set a level of
transparency and accountability were
there of the future democracy they
intended to bring to Sudan General
berkhan knew exactly what he had to do
and no he was not alone Sudan hametti
emerges from the Shadows to support
buran's Coop Western donors and
multilateral Banks had pledged billions
of dollars to support the democratic
transition but this coup by General
berhan and hamedete in October 2021
prevented much of that aid from reaching
Sudan
[Music]
the United States the world World Bank
and the IMF stopped the flow of at least
1.4 billion dollars in Aid and debt
relief to Sudan the military Junta then
had to cut wheat and fuel subsidies the
situation in Sudan became untenable and
the military was forced to negotiate
with civilians again to advance the
democratic transition last December they
reached an agreement Sudan to establish
new civilian-led transitional government
on April 11th the problem with these
agreements with the military is that the
military has a lot to hide General
berhan wants to protect what Sudanese
Democrats call the Deep State we are
talking about a whole network of
Corporations from Banks and
telecommunications companies owned by
islamists and Intelligence Officers to
companies owned by the Armed Forces
itself that dominate economic sectors
such as arms manufacturing construction
Agriculture and transportation something
similar could be said of hemedati who in
recent years has become the African
pregozian
is much more than just a warlord
dictator Bashir let the janjaweed take
control of the country's illicit gold
mines particularly in the Darfur region
making hamedete one of the richest men
in the country he also gained even more
money and allies by using his rapid
support forces as mercenaries in the
service of the United Arab Emirates to
fight in Yemen against the houthi rebels
and in Libya alongside General Khalifa
haftar
the new transitional government put
Sudan's two most powerful men on the
ropes the terms were clear Sudan would
have one single Army under the command
of the civilian government and the rapid
support forces would have to be
integrated into it this clearly
threatened the privileged possession of
both that of General burhan since the
agreement set Democratic elections for
2024 and also that of hamadetti since
within two years he had to integrate his
militia into the army something that the
African production intended to delay for
a decade therefore the only way out for
both was armed combat to see which of
the two would Prevail in deciding the
future of Sudan and so the country's
capital is taking the brunt of it
streets of Khartoum are devastated by
military conflict the problem with this
conflict is that it is a balanced fight
it will be difficult for either side to
Prevail the Sudanese Armed Forces is not
worth much but it has Aviation
[Music]
the rapid support forces are better
armed and more skilled in combat thanks
to their experience as mercenaries their
soldiers have had no qualms about taking
over homes schools and even hospitals to
fortify themselves in Khartoum and to
take the fight one street at a time now
the armed forces have intensively
bombarded the capital and as if this
were not enough the fighting has spread
to the rest of Sudan resurrecting old
ghosts from the past that threatened to
lead to another ethnic conflict check
this out Darfur Aid workers witnessed
hundreds of murdered bodies including
children abandoned in streets the janja
weed raid again and the risk of further
genocide gains momentum as the conflict
drags on hemedati stands as the rebel
force that has risen up against the
legitimate government of Sudan but the
latter is also questionable given that
the coup record of the general berhan
who is not exactly the best friend of
Sudanese Democrats the support of
foreign powers could tip the balance one
way or the other and there are many
interested stick what interests are we
talking about well we're going to take a
look at that no
[Music]
The Treasure of the Red Sea
foreign
the main powers in the Red Sea are Saudi
Arabia and Egypt it is therefore in
their interest to maintain the status
quo in the area this means in Sudan as
well especially after the fall of the
Bashir dictatorship which has moved very
close to its Rivals turkey and Qatar
Saudi Arabia and Egypt were comfortable
with the military Junta of berhan and
hamedati their main objective in Sudan
was to prevent a democratic revolution
in the Arab world that is why they
supported post Bashir Sudan Saudi Arabia
pledged to invest 3 billion dollars but
wait a minute because the United armor
of Emirates doubled that bet why so much
interest the Red Sea holds the answer
UAE to build port in Sudan as part of
six billion dollar investment package
despite being traditional allies as you
can imagine this emirati port is of no
interest to either Saudi Arabia or Egypt
what's more riyadh's favorite is general
berhan who is also General al-sisi's
favorite because of the close ties
between the Sudanese and Egyptian armies
however visual politic Community I have
already told you that the uae's man in
Sudan is hemedati so all the these
crossed interests tie in with Abu
dhabi's growing strategy to deploy its
full economic potential to rival Saudi
Arabia as the Arab world's benchmark
[Music]
while Prince bin Salman fell out of
favor in the West after khashoggi's
brutal murder the United Arab Emirates
has tried to portray itself as the
friendly face of the region in the end
they have shown different interests in
Yemen and in Washington where Abu Dhabi
has tried to replace Riyadh as America's
favorite military ally in the Gulf
when Salman has not shied away from the
Rivalry and is now trying to make up
lost ground we can see S at the sporting
level the Emirates by Manchester City so
the Saudis by Newcastle there's Formula
One in Abu Dhabi so there's Formula One
now in Saudi Arabia and so on and so
forth therefore returning to the war in
Sudan right now the priority of the
regional Powers is not so much peace but
rather that the side they support
prevails even more so if we add the
Wagner group into the equation the gold
that hemedati gets in Sudan is being
smuggled to Russia through the Emirates
it has taken the White House a while but
it has finally made a move against Abu
Dhabi take a look at this two arms
companies linked to the Sudanese Army
have been sanctioned by the U.S
meanwhile al-junade a gold trading
operation controlled by hemeti and his
brother and UAE based tradiv have also
been sanctioned the Wagner's group's
links to himadetti date back to 2017.
foreign
ER would have given weapons and military
training to the rapid support forces in
exchange for access to Sudan's gold
Russia's economy is being propped up by
Wagner group's gold smuggling operations
UK government report says Sudan's gold
is too attractive for the Kremlin to
drop hemedati berhan also has good
support with Saudi Arabia which in 2022
was the world's fifth largest military
spender behind only the United States
China Russia and India so all
indications are that the war in Sudan is
going to drag on we will be watching
closely as these conflicts tend to
unleash enormous amounts of violence in
the meantime the question is over to you
how do you think the situation in Sudan
will evolve will any of the foreign
powers be directly involved you can
leave me your answer in the comments
Below in the meantime don't forget that
we release new videos every week so
subscribe to this Channel and hit the
little bell button down there so you
don't miss any of our updates if you
like this video like it so we know all
the best I hope you enjoyed it and I'll
see you next time
[Music]
thank you